サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチットパリヨダパナン エタングブッダナササナナン
いや 今年の最初の講演でございますので
皆様に新年の祝福をいたします
祝福に過ぎてなんですけど
お釈迦様がダンボはウェラーカディダンマチャーリーという言葉が有名な言葉がございまして
その意味はね 真理に従って生きる人々は真理によって守られます
という 宗教の世界では
祝福 祝福 あれやこれやとかね
ものすごく考えてはいるんだけど
お祈りやら祈祷やらね
やっぱりちょっとおかしいところがあるんですね
我々の欲望をかき立てられますね
商売繁盛とかね 学 なんたらかんたら成就とかね
この欲望をかき立てることと
このライバルに対して勝ちたいというところは怒りですからね
そういうものをかき立てる祈りっていうのはすごく危険なんですね
結局逆効果になるんですね
だからお釈迦様は本当に人々を祝福しているんです
それはものすごい抜群に効き目があります
そこは真理に従って生きてみてくださいと
それだけですと 欲望をかき立てることではなくて
私は人間として正しい生き方していますと
それはブッダに説かれた教えであるということ
気持ちが心にあれば もう日常生活
すごく幸せになります
皆様に至ってもね 家族の間でいろいろトラブルがあるし
会社でいたってもね うまくいかないというトラブルがあるでしょうし
経済状況もね うまくいかないっていうね
また 体の健康の問題もあるでしょうし
こんなのはどんな人間にもあることで
それから一番困ったことは
この予測意外 何かドカンと来ることがありますね
そういうものからしっかりと自分を守られます
問題ないんです ブッダの教えをちゃんと自分にできる範囲で
素直で頑張ってみてください
そんなに新興宗教ではありませんし
宗教でもないんだから
ただ理性に基づいて生きるだけなんですね
やっぱりこういうを発見した
この解脱に達した智慧を開いたお釈迦様が
ものすごい人間の生命の唯一指導者であると
そこは自分が納得している場合は
もう不安は一切なし 恐怖感は一切なく生きられます
ものすごい証拠があるんです
ですから 皆様にはいきなり難しいんだからね
やっぱり気持ちは中途半端で
仏教もやっぱり興味はあるんだけど
まあでもなんだらかんたらとかね
そういう曖昧中途半端な気分になってくると
この仏法僧の力によって守ることがちょっとできなくなるんですね
だから素直で真理に従って生きていますと
いうふうなことになると
この素直な心だった これはあればもう問題はないんです
そういうわけで 皆様も仏法僧にちゃんと守られますようにと願い
切願いたします 皆様もそういうふうに考えておいてください
ブッダの説かれた生き方を実践しましょう
日常生活における問題も
精神的な悩みもなくなって
安穏に生きられます ということで
新年の挨拶を終了いたします
では これからすごい簡単に
しゃべりしゃべるかなと思ってたんだけど
結局は難しい内容になってしまったんです
今日のテーマはね まず因縁法則と無常という真理
これはお釈迦様に説かれた真理なんですね
すべての現象は因縁によって現れて
因縁によって必ずなくなります
これ真面目に理解した方がよろしいのです
この存在の中で 宇宙の中で
すべての生命の中で これが真理なんです
すべて因縁によって生まれるんです
この光と同じ あらゆる原因が揃って光があるんであって
だから光自体が永久的じゃないんです
原因が変わったらさっと消えてしまいます
我々の命もそうなんです
他宗教が語られている存在すらもしない
絶対的な神々もそんなもんなんです
無常でないものは何も存在しないんです
これは無常という真理です
無常にならざるものはないのです
因縁を調整することによって
無常の流れを変えることも可能です
そこはいいポイントなんです
電気が流れるんだから
もう照明がありますね
でもいろいろある程度で工夫できますね
例えば この照明の前に色のついた紙を貼ったら
光が赤い紙を貼ったら赤くなったり
青い紙を貼ったら青くなったりもします
あるいはこの照明の前に何か動くようにしておけば
こちらで影が動いているように見えたりする
そうやって我々にちょっと因縁を変えることでいろんな工夫できます
しかし 因縁そのものを変えることはできません
例えばイルミネーションというものがあるでしょ
光でいろんな模様を変えたり
もういろんなことを演奏したりもしますね
彼らが何をやっているのかというと
この電気があって 電気流れると光が現れるという
これは LED であろうが
普通の電球であろうが関係ない
この法則は変わりません
その中で手を加えるんですね
手を加えるということは
因縁をちょこちょこっと調整する
因縁を変えるではなくて調整する
因縁を壊すではなくて調整するなんです
お釈迦様はこの法則を完成したんです
因縁を調整することというのは完成してみせたんです
はい それで次のテーマに入ります
世界の発展と仏教の道
世界も因縁の調整で 物事を自分の希望通りに変えられることを知っています
因縁法則 ほとんどみんな無関心で気にしない
しかし これが真理だから
無視したってもうむちゃくちゃですよ
しかし 人間が因縁を変えて
希望通りに物事を変化できるということだけは知っているんです
しかし これは因縁法則だと知らないんですね
科学文化などの発展はその結果です
今 世の中は 21 世紀でかなりいろんなもの変わってるでしょ
昔と違って 我々食べるご飯さえも昔食べたご飯と違うでしょうに
きゅうりでもトマトでもね
昔の自然なものとは違うんですね
だからそれは因縁を変えているんですよ
この人々は因果法則を無視しながら
トマトはどうすれば丸い形になるのかとか
どうすればより甘くなるのかとかね
どうすればあの酸っぱさがなくなるのかとかね
もう変えるんですよ 例えば世界でのリンゴといえばね
日本のリンゴは まあもしかすると世界で一番おいしいリンゴかもしれません
世界的に見ても 中国なんかはかなり高い値段で売れても売れてるし
売れている それで日本では自然のリンゴは 1個もないんです
全部 あのリンゴの農家の方々はもうかなり大学で研究して
いろいろ学んでリンゴを変えているんですよ
大きさやら色やら味やら歯触りやら
いろんなものを変えて変えて変えて変えて
今 人間の好みで 人間の希望通りに
自然のリンゴではなくて
食いたいリンゴを作っているんです
だからそれ調整なんですよ
因縁法則を リンゴそのものの法則を変えることはできません
調整しているんです それで人間の希望が叶っている
このビルやら建物やら
このサウンドシステムやら
何にしても 人間が因縁法則を工夫することで開発しているものなんです
しかし 精神の流れを調整するべきだと思っていないんです
この科学者と人間のおかしいところは
科学者も因縁法則をいじっているのに
農家の方々も因縁法則をいじっているのに
芸術家も絵を描く人も
漫画を描く人も これ因縁法則をいじっているんです
漫画っていうのはただの何か線を描くだけでしょ
でも線が脳に入ったらどんな現象を作るのかとよう知っていて
それで紙の上で感情まで表して見せちゃうんです
紙の上でどうやって感情を表せますかね
ありえないでしょうに
でも漫画のキャラを見たらね
我々が悲しがっている
怒っているとかわかるでしょう
その気持ち 心に生まれるでしょうに
だからこの人々は因果法則はまるっきり知らん
なのに その工夫をしているんです
で そこで因果法則を知らないだけではなくて
もう一つ大きな 一番大事なポイント
完璧無関心 精神 私たちは生きているんだから
こういうくだらんものいっぱい必要になってるでしょうに
服もビルも建物も あれやこれや
金も何でも欲しい欲しい必要必要ってなってるのは
この生きているからでしょう
生きているというのは
物体の中に精神が働いているからでしょうに
だから精神で何なのかと
そちらの因果法則は何なのかと
それはどのように調整するべきか
それはもう世界ではないんです
お釈迦様の教え以外は
もうこれ申し訳ないんだけど
存在しないんです そのポイントは人間どうするのかというと
迷信 信仰 神などに任せているんです
だから科学やら文明一番勢いで発達したのは最近ね
西洋の方でしょ 精神のことは
それは神様 よう恥ずかしくなくて
あの神様は信仰するは
ローマ教皇は神みたいな感じで
まあ何やってるのかと
あまりにも原始的な その点では
それで落ち着いているんです
だから科学的に見てみなさいよと言いたいんだけど
神はいるかいないかとかね
神がなんかいじってるのかとかね
それはどうでもいいんです
だから人類の中で どんな国でもいっぱい迷信があります
ものすごいたくさんないろんな信仰があります
神がいるわ いるわいるわ
本当に神が実際するなれば
こんなもう好き勝手な神作れないでしょうに
人間がはっきり好き勝手に神を作っているんです
だって日本人 日本にある神々とインドの神々が違うんだから
これで中国人が信仰している神様また違うんだから
チベット人が信仰している神々また違う
西洋の神々 中東の神々
これいるわ いるわ ということで
自分の精神的な問題になってくると
そうやってもう非科学的で根拠のない
証拠は一切ない迷信に委ねるんです
お釈迦様は精神の発展を完成した
お釈迦様の違うところは迷信一切なし
精神とは何や それは因果法則に沿って調べて完成するんです
だから人間に必要なのは
何よりもブッダに説かれた真理の道なんです
これは人間だけじゃなくて
他の生命にも必要なんです
だから仏典ではいろんな次元の神々が来て
お釈迦様と対話して学んでいくエピソードは結構あるんです
それはただの神話物語じゃないんです
神がこうやって尋ねました
お釈迦様がこのように答えた
ちゃんと教えがあるんです
だから そういうことを学ぶと
私たちは勝手におろか者たちが無知な人間が作った神ではなくて
実際存在する神々にはどんな問題があるのかと研究することさえもできます
だから私はこの神という言葉ですけど
そのある次元の違った存在は否定しませんよ
いることを知っています
しかし 皆様方と一般人が思っている神という概念とは全く違う
で 私から見れば まあ我々には我々の問題がありまして
神々には神々の世界の問題がありますと
それで私たちとしては
もうもうどうすれば儲かるのかということで
必死で 神々のそれなりにかなり必死なトラブル問題があるんです
だからそこはどんなものかと仏典を読んでみれば見えてくるんです
そうすると まあ拝まなくてもいいやと
私たちは助けてくれるかというと
そんな暇はないんだとわかるんですよ
だって 私にしたって皆様を助けてあげたい気持ちはあるんですよ
あるんだけど できるのですかね
できないんです 気持ちで終わっちゃうんです
幸福でありますようにと
そういうことだから 世界はあまりにもおかしくて
精神の問題になってくると
それは迷信任せにしているんです
はい それから仏教の世界にあります
学ぶ道 パーリ語でシッカというんですね
まあ英訳もしましたけど
path of ディシプリン
だから仏教とはレリジョン
宗教でしょうかというと
答えが仏教とは path of ディシプリンなんです
宗教ではないんです 科学でもないんです
哲学でもないんです 煩悩
宗教でもない 反科学ではない
どちらでもない パートディシプリン
大体皆様ディシプリンという言葉はご存知でしょうか
と思いますけどね ディシプリンって普通日本語で言えば何でしたっけね
しつけ？みたいなもんなんですね
しつけはいらないと思う？しつけによって成り立っています
すべて ブッダの教えは宗教ではなく
学ぶ道です 戒定慧という三段階で学ぶ道は終着点に達します
皆様 仏教の用語を知っている方々は三学という言葉はご存知だと思います
ティシッカーとパーリ語で言います
日本語で三学 三つの学ぶというね
感じで それは三段階 戒っていうのは生き方
喋り方 歩き方 食べ方 あれやこれやとか生き方のしつけ
定っていうのは精神のしつけ
育てること 精神を向上させること
慧っていうのは知恵 真理を発見するという道
その三つの学で仏教なんです
だから宗教でも科学でも何でもないんです
すべての生命は輪廻転生しながら生きる苦しみを回転しています
これは因果法則の教え
因果法則から見れば 何か原因があって何か現れる
それで原因は不完全だから現れたものは消えちゃう
消えるということも原因なんですね
それで別なものが現れているんです
ガラスは原因によって現れていて
何か力が入っちゃうとガラス割れてしまいますね
破片になります それはまた原因になるんです
ガラス破片は次にどうなるのかと
消えるということは ガラスはきれいさっぱり無になったということじゃないんです
紙カップで何か飲んで
紙カップは終了終わりましたではないんです
終わりませんよ 紙カップも転生するんです
たとえ燃やしても しかし
前と今は随分 例えば紙カップを取って水を飲む
飲んでから紙カップを燃やす
紙カップがなくなっちゃった
でも別なものが生まれたんです
はい 紙カップの魂が煙やら空気に入ったんで
そんなのはないんです
ただ変わった 変わったら元何でしたっかってわからないんです
例えば 私たちに灰を見て
この灰はもと紙カップでしたと言える？言えません
たまに新聞なんか燃やしたらたまに見えます
なぜならばインクがね
灰の中に時々残ったりするんだから
これ新聞紙を燃やしたものと言えるんだけど
それちょこっと潰しちゃったらそれもできない
この灰を水に溶かして植物にあげたら
植物は変化する これは朝日新聞を栄養にしたきゅうりだよと言えます
言えません そうやってなんかすごいことですよ
この変化って流れが終わらないんです
その中で最大の力を持っているのは精神なんです
物質じゃないんです このパルサーとかね
新星とか宇宙であるでしょ
今日はタイム雑誌で記事があって
何でしたっけ ブラックホール2つがお互いにぶつかろうとしているんだと
ブラックホールっていうのはあんまりにも壮大なパワーなんですね
宇宙の中でももう大物なんですね
ブラックホールっていうのは
いろんな至る所にたくさんありましてね
今二人がなんとなくお互いに近寄ってきて
お互いぐるぐる回っているんだと
とにかくもうぶつかっちゃって
吸収合併するんだって
そのうち それからどうなるかよくわかりません
詳しく読んでないんだから
ちょっとヘッドラインだけでね
もう口輪に黒羽になりましたからね
それ読んでいる時 そういうことで
星 が壊れたりしてね 時々吸収したりして
ブラックホールが現れる
ブラックホールと我々でこれって随分違うんですよね
だから転生はするんだけど
元どうなったかとわからないんです
例えば皆様方の子供の頃の写真と今の写真
例えば子供の写真もいろんな子供
子供 5人の写真を撮って
その子供 5人の大人の写真を撮って
この二人 この 10人を5人を全く知らない人に写真だけ見せて
この子供はこの大人です
この子供はこの大人ですと合わせてくださいと
クイズだったらできると思う
相当難しいんです これ
赤ちゃんの写真だったら
赤ちゃん 5人の写真っていうのはほとんど同じですからね
これ 大人 5人の写真っていうのはそれぞれすごく違いますよ
それを知らない人に見せたら合わせてくださいと
絶対無理です 今 私たちの顔を形見て
私たちの赤ちゃんの姿を想像できる
そうできる科学者がいる
いないんです 今も我々は転生していて
もうかつてどうなったかとわからない状態に
今が今いるんです はい
それは因果法則で輪廻転生で
そこで生命がすごい精神的な力を持ってるんだから
なんで精神的な力が宇宙の力よりすごいんでしょうかね
この物質を変えること
精神にできます 宇宙にできません
宇宙では物質は変わるだけなんです
たとえブロック 子供が遊んでいるブロックというものがあるんですね
ブロックを組み立てて何か怪獣を作るというのは
それは宇宙の物質ではできないんです
我々人間に同じ形のブロックを組み
組み立てて 組み立てて
はい 怪獣ですとかね はい
お家ですとか作ることができます
宇宙はどう何億年経っても
例えばウサギの絵は描けませんよ
人間がすぐ筆を とウサギのよう描く
だからこの物事を変化させる
変化するものなんですけど
別な形にするっていうことは生命にできるんです
例えば他の惑星と地球っていうのは随分違うんですよ
これ ただこちらで水あるからではなくて
地球はなぜ違うのかというと
生命がいるんだからなんです
生命がいるんだから土が違うんです
植物があるんだから地球が変わるんです
他の生き物がいるんだからね
だから物質そのものが変わっていくんですね
だからといって根本的に変えることはできませんだけど
で 変わっちゃうんですね
というわけで ブラックホールにもできないこと
ブラックホールできるのは
隣にあるものは全部吸収するだけなんですね
太陽がその隣にあったら
太陽はすっと飲み込む
それで終わり 太陽は何個でも
何のひっちゃで丸ごと飲み込む
太陽はあなたこちら あなたこちらと並べてください
それはできません もし生命にブラックホールぐらい力があったならば
あの あなたは太陽なんであちらに行ってくださいと
あなたはこちらですよとずらしてあげることができるんです
生命にはそこまではどうかなと思いますが
だからこの精神の力っていうのは
宇宙の物質の力よりはすごいんです
そういうわけで 宇宙も過去状態にならない
前どうなったかわからないんだけど
変化して変化していく
精神もそのように 今の精神
次の瞬間で消える 新たな精神
その精神は次の瞬間で消えて
新たな精神 今の我々は転生しつつなんです
私たちの 私の気持ちがすーっと恐ろしいスピードで変化しているんです
皆様の気持ちもそうなんです
恐ろしいスピードで変化しているんです
2 3分経ったら 前の気持ちどうなったかわからないんです
それぐらい輪廻転生しているんです
スピーディーに そこで生きることは
お釈迦様が全体的にこの苦というファンクションであると
苦しみというエネルギーで生きているんだと
物質と精神がぶつかると
嫌な気持ちが生まれるんです
気分が良くなるわけじゃないんです
この嫌な気持ちをなんとかしようということで
生命が輪廻転生するんです
だから生きるということは苦です
そこで私たちはここで死んじゃったっても
これ肉体が停止しただけで
精神は停止しなくて変わるんですね
ただ 過去どうなったかわからないだけで
将来どうなるのかとわからないだけでわかるはずもない
人に灰を見せて この灰はどんなものの灰でしょうかと聞いたっても
わかるわけないでしょうに
そういう感じで 我々の輪廻転生はね
わかりませんと偉そうなこと言ったってわかりませんよ
わかりません だからといって
それは嘘というはおかしいでしょう
私にわからないものはすべて嘘やと
冗談ですね そう言ったら
だから輪廻転生は輪廻転生です
ブッダの智慧で説かれているんです
一般人にはわかりませんとお釈迦様も言っているんです
そこで生命が輪廻転生しながら何をやっているのかというと
苦しみを回転しているんです
学ぶ道を選ぶ生命のみ
他の生命と違って精神的に進化して完全な自由を獲得するんです
そこで大宇宙にないことをお釈迦様が推薦するんです
学ぶ道を選びましょうよと
このずっと苦しみのルーテンはアホくさくてバカバカらしいやと
例えば宇宙だったらビッグバンから現れて膨張して
それからまた爆発しちゃって
それから収縮する それどんどんどんどんビッグクランチ
すべて壊れてしまう で
またビッグバンで こればっかり繰り返すんですよ
だから一応計算していますから
ビッグバンと今の時間はね
あれはまあそこそこ計算ですけど
この 素粒子がね まあ膨張するスピード知ってますからね
膨張しているスピードから逆算計算して
こんな年代でビッグバンが起きたと言ってますからね
こんなものは際限なく繰り返すんだとお釈迦様もおっしゃっているんです
面白くないんです で 私たちも生まれては死ぬ
死んでは生まれる 生まれては死ぬ
死んでは生まれる どこまでやっているのかと
だから皆様方 お釈迦様があんまりも膨大なスケールで真理を発見するんだから
これって面白くないんだと
飽きちゃったんです 輪廻転生
だって苦しみの転生だから
ですから このシステムを学びましょうよ
何か学んじゃいましょうと
学ぶと因果法則を調整するんです
学んだ人はね だから科学を学んだ人がいろんな品物を作られます
科学知らない私には何も作ることはできません
今 電子時代で IC 時代でね
新たな新たなもの 次から次へと現れてるでしょうに
携帯にしたって あらゆるアップ
アップが出たり いろんなことゲームがあったり
これ私にはできません
なぜかというと学んでないんです
で プログラミングを学んでいる人々はいろんなゲーム開発しちゃって
それを売っちゃって金儲かっているんです
IC 技術を知っている人々は
もう機械ハードウェアを開発して進んでいくんですね
だから学んだら何かできる
因果法則の調整できる
この調整がそんなに悪くないんです
昔は指でダイヤル 昔は手で回す電話でしたでしょ？テレビで見たことあるでしょ
手で回して 耳に何かつけて
もしもしとか何とか言っていて
それから指でダイヤル回せるようになっちゃって
今どうですかね 今は携帯でもう親指でちょっと電話番号のあるところで
それで指で押すだけで
それでつながる 相手がいなくても
相手はこの人から電話ありましたと知っている
だからあれは調整でしょ
悪い そんなに悪くないでしょ
ですから 学んだ人は因果法則を調整する
因果法則を調整するときは
自分の希望に 好みに 便利に合わせて調整するんです
だからはっきりしてるでしょ
答えは 人なら学ぶ道を選ぶんです
嫌がるんじゃないんです
嫌がったらとんでもない馬鹿もんなんです
学ぶ道は 単純明快 楽々じゃないんです
決して楽ちんじゃないんです
研究とかは 楽ちんじゃない
ちょっと苦しいんだからといって
それは蹴っ飛ばして否定する道じゃないんです
そこでお釈迦様が科学よりはるかに進んで精神を学びましょうという
科学を学びましょうではなくて
精神を学びましょう なぜ精神の因果法則を変えられます
これはなかなかいいものなんです
リンゴの味を変えることとは随分違います
例えば 我々はあれがない
これがないとか悩んでいるでしょうに
いわゆる精神が弱すぎ
雨が降ったら悩む 雪が降ったら悩む
地震が起きたら悩む 子供が風邪ひいたら悩む
旦那が会社から遅くなって帰るともう悩む
なんだこの心はと ただ風邪を引いただけで悩むんだから
あまりにも弱すぎ もし精神には自由があって
何があっても落ち着いている
喜びを感じている すごいでしょう
それだったら だって皆様
なんでアクセサリー買う？なんで豪華な服を買う？なんで立派な家を作る？喜びたいでしょ
喜びはどこにある？精神にあるんです
だから精神が喜ぶことがとても大事なことなんです
そのためにもう借金までして家を作るんです
借金までしてカバン買うんです
カバン買ったんだからって
ちっぽけな喜びでしょ
大した喜びじゃない しかし
我々は精神の喜びのためにはちゃめちゃなことをやっているんじゃないんですかね
それだったら精神を学んで
精神の因果法則を調整すれば
期待するあの喜び 幸福
安穏 安らぎが得られます
絶望しているもの はい
テーマに入ります 今までイントロダクション
知ってるつもり 成長を妨げる
最初の障害 生きる勇気を与える感情
生きるために判断して行動を起こさなくてはならない
生きるということは何かやっているんです
呼吸している 見る 聞く
喋る 座る 立つ 体は動いているんです
血液も動いている 細胞も動いているんです
まとめて私は喋っているんです
呼吸しているんです ご飯も食べているんです
だから行動することが生きることなんです
行動するためには判断が必要です
ご飯食べますと判断が必要です
うどんとラーメンとおにぎりと弁当並んでいると
判断しないと食べられないでしょう
判断します じゃあうどんにしますとかね
おにぎりにしますとか
判断できなかったら もうお腹が空いていても
ご飯は目の前にあったっても動きがないんです
だから我々はすーっと判断して行動しているんです
生きる作業は停止しないで流れるんです
ですから 生命は絶えず判断し続けて行為をしているのです
物事を知らないと判断は不可能です
何かしら知る必要があります
うどん ラーメン なんだら
丼 なんとかご飯 弁当 あれやこれやとかね
並んでいる場合は じゃあそばにする？ラーメンにする
うどんにする おにぎりにする
弁当にするとかね 一つ決めるでしょ
決める場合は知識が必要ですね
自分で決めるんだから
何か知る必要あるんです
例えば子供に聞けば 私はラーメン好きだからラーメンにしますといとも簡単に決めます
あんた体にいいんだから弁当
いや 面倒くさいんだから弁当は嫌ですと
それ 子供の知識なんです
この知る必要あります
判断するために この知ることは必ず正しくなければということはないんです
子供は簡単に食べますからとかね
すっごいごっついきつい味が過ぎてるんだから
もうラーメン食っちゃいますけど
親がラーメンはちょっとやめて弁当食べた方がいいのにと思っているんです
でも 子供は親の判断には乗りません
子供はお母さんの判断は私の判断より正しいんだから
お母さんの判断に従って生きていますとはありえないでしょ
だから判断が正しいかではなくて
知識は正しいかないか関係なく
何かしらの知識が必要なんです
ですから 皆知ってるつもりで精神的に落ち着くんです
だから知ることって面倒くさいでしょ
知ることできなかったら判断できないでしょ
だから知ってるつもりにするんです
この知ってるつもりは
私の判断が正しいと自己満足するためなんです
私 知ってる 知ってる これにしますと
いうことで 生命は知ってるつもりで生きているんです
問題は知っているのでしょうかなんですね
知る機能はあるが 承知は起こらないんです
我々にも犬猫にも知る機能はあるんです
ミミズにも知る機能があるんです
しかし それが承知ではないんです
皆様の子供の 皆様がご自分の子供のことを知ってるでしょ
子供はものごと知ってますけど
全然間違ってますね 間違ってますけど
子供は全然自分が正しいと思っているんです
時々お菓子ばっかし食ってる子供たちいますよ
チップスやらいろんなものを食べるは食べるは
もう大人から見れば何やってるのかこの子供はと
思ってるんだけど 子供は
いや これおいしい それで話終わり
だからみんなに知る機能があるんだけど
これが承知ではございません
皆 自分の都合に合わせて認識データを捏造します
知る機能があるんだだからデータが入るんです
入ったデータを我々は自分の都合で捏造するんです
例えば タバコを吸う人はタバコはいいと
あれやこれやと知識作るんです
酒飲む人はずっと酒がいいと
こういうわけでいい こういうわけでいいと
もう必死懸命必死で捏造しているんです
例えば 酒を飲まなきゃ友達付き合いできませんと真面目に言ってるでしょ
人付き合い 友達付き合いは
できませんと 酒いっぱい飲まなきゃと
では逆に考えてください
酒飲まない人はね もうより孤独で
人付き合いなく生活している
なんてアホなこと言ってるんですかね
完璧嘘でしょ 例えば子供たちも結構仲間で
大人よりもすごい仲間意識いいでしょうに
酒飲んでいる では大人に聞いてみてください
なんであんた酒 やっぱり酒飲まなきゃ社会でね
コミュニケーションとか友達付き合いとかは成り立ちませんよと
真っ赤な嘘を言っているのに
自分では嘘だと思っていないんです
捏造しているんです ということです
そういうわけで 酒飲む人に限らず
タバコを吸う人に限らず
我々みんな 認識データを捏造するんです
捏造しちゃったら 自分が本当のことを言っているという錯覚を起こるんです
変ですよ 自分が知る世界は自分だけに事実であり
他の生命にその通りということにはなりません
私が捏造したものは 私にとって事実
本物 本当のこと でも 他の人にとっては別にという感じなんです
生命の間で意見違いと自分を正当化する争いは絶えないね
だから 例えば酒飲む人が酒飲んだ方がいい
量を知って飲んだ方が健康にもいい
人付き合いもできる 信頼できるというスタンスでいる
それで酒嫌い人が いえ
違いますよという そうするとどうなるんですかね
対立が生まれる 日本人が和食は一番美味しいと思っている
中国人は中国料理は世界一だと思っている
ユダヤ人も本を読んでみたんだけど
世界でユダヤ人ほど 美味しい料理を作る人間が存在しませんと書いているんです
私は勝手に言いなさいと思いつつも
本を読みました 終わりまで
ユダヤ人が書いた本でしたけどもね
そこでどうなるんですかね
争いが生まれるんです
で 昔ではなくて ある何年か前の話であまり日にちは覚えていないし
これもタイムスの記事からちょっと読んで覚えたデータなんで
エジプトで イギリス人の女性の先生がね
学校で英語を教えていて
そこでみんなの中でこの
英語のすごい上手な子供に何かプレゼントをあげるということで
このぬいぐるみを 1つ
何のぬいぐるみだったっけ？このクマのね
テディベアの結構いいものをね
で これ点数の一番いい子にあげましょうということで
一応学校クラスに置いておいてね
それである男の子がすごい優秀で
この子の名前はモハメドなんですね
それで この先生が子供たちと遊んでいるんだから
ではこのテディベアに名前をつけましょうと
じゃあ この子が一番勉強はよくできたんだから
みんなこの子どものこの子の名前をつけましょうよと言ったら
みんなはい 賛成ということで
テディベアの名前はモハメドにしたんです
次の日 たくさん暴動が起きちゃって
人々が来て武器を持って
あの女を殺せと イスラム教は冒涜しまったと侮辱しましたと
聖なんだらかんだらかのプロフェットモハメッドをね
侮辱したんだと もう生きる権利はないんだと
直ちに逮捕して処刑にしてくださいと大騒ぎしたんで
で イギリス政府もものすごくかゆい
で なんとかその女性をね
逮捕させました されましたけど
なんとかイギリスに戻させ
戻られたんです 殺されて済みましたけど
あのバカどもたちがわからないのは
イスラム人の男の場合はだいたい 7割の名前はモハメドなんです
なのにこの連中にわからないのは
モハメドと言ってた時点で
どうやって預言者モハメド侮辱したことになるんですかね
だったらその連中でしょうに
イスラム人の名前って言ったら
モハメド なんだらかんだら
それいいんですかね だから
人間っていうのは 自分の都合で感情でデータをねつ造するんです
データをねつ造して 我は正しい
お前が間違ってる だからお前は殺すべき
このフランスのテロ行為は起きたでしょ
同じ話なんです それで私たちは平和だと思っても
平和じゃないでしょ 夫婦は喧嘩する
兄弟は喧嘩する 友達同士で喧嘩する
いっぱい喧嘩あるでしょうに
それはすべてねつ造した自分の意見と相手のねつ造した意見が合わないからなんです
だから 例えば 10人である
有名な絵画を鑑賞しましょう
しかし 私は私なりにねつ造する 10
人も10人なりにねつ造する
それでみんな自分のねつ造したことで語り合うんです
絵画のことじゃないんです
私はあの絵画がなんか暗いイメージだなと思う
いえ 私はそれをすごくなんだらかんだら感動的な絵画だなと
いえ 私はそれすごくこの人間の美を表している
とても明るい くだらんことばっかりで
それでこの10人が喧嘩する
絵画は関係ないんです
絵画から入ったデータをねつ造しちゃって
ねつ造したものが真理だと勘違いして争うんです
事実を確かめるより 私見が正しいと主張するんです
私は知らないとは賢者の道
これで我々は私が知っているという立場でいるんです
恐ろしい生命なんです
ねつ造ばっかりしているくせに
ヨーバローマンヤティバーリアン
パンディトゥワーピテーナソー
バローパンディタマーニセウェイバローと打ちたい
ダンマパダの 63 番の有名な偈です
無知な人は無知を気になっているならば
無知な人 私たちみんな無知だからね
でも自分の無知さに無知であることは気になるんですね
俺がバカで困ったなと
頭が悪くてこれは困っちゃったなとか気になってるんですね
それによりその人は 賢者になるんですと
それで賢者になるんだよと
知ってるつもりでいる無知な
ちょっと文章おかしい
知っているつもりでいる無知な人はなんですね
確かに愚か者であります
だからねつ造して私は正しいと思ったらどうなるんですかね
正真正銘の愚か者になるんです
それでも一般人は知っているという想定で生きているのです
みんな知ってる 知ってる
知ってるっていう想定で
その変なとんでもない想定がなければ生きていられなくなるんです
知っていると先はありません
知っているつもりになったら
成長 進化は止まり 退化が始まります
あ 知ってます 言ったら退化です
成長止まります 宗教と信仰の世界でよくある現象です
宗教は人類を退化させる世界なんです
決して人類にとって微塵も慈しみのある組織ではありません
いかに進歩を止めて退化させようかと思っているんです
皆様は目がくらんでいて
そうやって自由な観察能力がないんだから
私の話は理解できないかも
私は何の感情もなく 純粋客観的に歴史を見ると
宗教ほど人間に迷惑をかけた組織はないんじゃないかなと思うんです
戦争が起きますよ 戦争が起きてすぐ終わります
宗教のいじめはずっと続くんです
それから宗教はとにかくこの科学に反対
進歩に反対 新たなものに反対
あれやこれ 例えばイスラム教の女性の方々は
でっかい袋をかぶって生活しなくちゃいけないんですね
おしゃれでもしなさい
ダメです 反対です そういうことで
あれに反対 これに反対
なぜかというと 真理は神の言葉にありきと
で くだらない何か書いちゃって
それが真理 それで知ってるつもり
神がアダムとイブを作りません
はい  OK 知ってます 真理
終わり これほど危険なことはないんですよ
世の中には そういうわけで
この聖書類とかね こういう宗教書っていうのはね
いろいろありまして 俺は知ってる態度で語っているんです
新興宗教も同じなんです
俺には神様が耳元で喋ってくれるんだと
だからお前聞きなさいと
地獄という脅しと天国という約束で
人の考える自由をストップさせます
だからこのこれで終わり
これは真理 これは知っていると
ここで心を止めようとしているんです
真理の探求ができないように心を洗脳します
だから知らないということがありがたいんです
何も知らん 俺は阿呆 これ困ったという気持ちがあったら賢者になるんです
それで我々は真理を探求するんです
これはこの知ってるつもり世界はすべてストップさせるんです
はい 次に知識とはどんなものかと
人間が人間として生きるために
他の生命と競争して生き延びるために獲得する能力です
私は見事な定義だと思ってますけどね
皆様そう思ってないでしょ？私のねつ造だからね
で 知識っていうのは 人間が人間として生きるために
また他の生命と競争して生き延びるために獲得する能力のことです
真理のことじゃないんです
知識は真理ではなく 自分の都合でねつ造したデータの結論です
知識っていうのは ねつ造したデータから作る結論なんです
人間の次元を超えた知識は現れません
だから人間はいくら勉強しても
人間の知識は人間の次元にリミットされます
だって知識っていうのは生きるためにあるものだからね
この肉体を維持するためにあるものだから
宇宙科学も金儲かって気分良くなっちゃって生きるためなんです
だって ブラックホールがぶつかったってもどうったことないでしょうに
あまりにも遠く起こるものだから影響ないんですよ
我々にとっては 放っておいたらいいんです
あるいはそこら辺のこの我々のギャラクシーの中で
何か太陽が突然爆発しちゃって
あの放射線がね 宇宙線がドカーンと地球に来たら
そんなのは知ったっても知らなくてもどうでもいいんです
地球の生命は一発で死にますからね
知ったんだからで逃げられません
でしょ 宇宙船に乗って逃げたっても
宇宙の出来事だからね
逃げる場所はないんです
だからどうでもいいんです
そんなのは でも知ってると気分がいいんです
金が入るんです そういうわけで
人間の知識はすべて人間の次元に限ったものです
他の生命にも生き延びるために必要な知識があります
人間言ってるすごい大きな嘘があります
人間には知識があります
他の生命に知識がありませんと
神様は人間が他の生命の王として創りましたと
他の生命を自由自在に殺して食べて生きるために作ったと
すごい教えですね あまりにも劣等してわがまま好き勝手な考えでしょ
だから犬猫はバカだと思っているんです
豚はアホやと思っているんです
ロバとか馬とか鶏とか
ああまあ魂も何もない生命やと
アホやバカやと 本当にそうですかね
私は時々びっくりするほど
私は動物の中で知識発見するんです
びっくりしますよ 時々
予測の能力とか 時々私よりも上手に予測するんです
それで人間のことはわからないんだけど
私は結構犬猫を馬鹿にするんですね
からかっちゃうんで いろんなことを言って
で 言葉はわからないんだけど
からかわれてるんではないかっていう
あの態度が面白いんです
ですから もう知識がないというのはあまりにもおかしいんですよ
だから鶏には あの三掛さんはわかりませんだけど
生きるために必要な知識があります
猫にも生きるために必要な知識があります
だから生きてるんです
はい 次 知識の短所 できるだけ早く行きます
存在欲と恐怖感が知識を求める衝動になります
なんで我々は知識を求めるかというと
存在欲と恐怖感 知識はその目的を超えません
知識いくら増えても 存在欲と恐怖感という壁は乗り越えられません
知識だけでは人格向上はできません
ですから 知識では人格向上はありません
ただ存在欲 それから恐怖感
そこを何とかしようと
生きることを楽にしてくれるという側面だけに目がくらんで
知識が与える悩み 苦しみ
不安 感情の暴走などに気づきません
我々は知識はありがたい
知識はありがたいと思っているだけで
知識から与えてくれた楽な生き方に目がくらんでいるんです
客観的に見てないんです
本当は知識は楽だけではなく
かなり苦しみ かなり悩み
かなり不安を与えているんです
かなり感情の暴走 知識によって生まれるんです
世界戦争も知識から生まれるんです
自然破壊も知識の結果なんです
原爆も知識の結果なんです
これは無視しましょう
携帯あるんだから 知識の結果でなんて素晴らしい世界ですかと
だから楽にしたところだけ見ているんですね
データを列挙することが知識ですね
都合と要求が変わるたびに
ねつ造の仕方も変わります
だから知識と真理関係ない
知識とはデータをねつ造する
都合が変わったら別なことをねつ造する
ねつ造に終わり 最終結論などはありません
知り終えたということはありません
まああるでしょう 時々
昔はね バナナ食べたらダイエットになるんだとねつ造しちゃったんで
それでみんなバナナ食っていたんですね
バナナダイエットとか言って
これで 1年  2年  3年ぐらい経ってくると
バナナは悪いんだと 砂糖いっぱい入ってるんだから太るんだと
別なダイエットしているんです
なんだらかんだらダイエットとかね
だから都合に希望によってねつ造変わるんですよ
これで終わりがないんです
人間がダイエットになる食べ物はね
それからも次から次へと
もういろんなものに飛ぶでしょうね
何やっても結果は同じですけど
そんなのはどうでもいいんです
それはどうでもいいんです
何かに飛び込む ある時期はもう散歩をすればもうスマートになるとかね
ある時は泳げばと 勝手にやってくださいとね
だからまあ 毎日テレビを見ていると
今日の熱はということで
前のことと違ったものは出てくるんです
終わりがないんです だから知識には終了がないんです
いつだって未完成で かつて知識は不完全でしたと認めるが
今の知識に頼る みんな本当に笑っちゃう現象なんですよ
昔みんなバカでしたねとかね
いろんなこと言ってるでしょ
昔は科学もそんなに進んでなくて
麻酔もなく麻酔もなくて
ろくな薬もなくて大変でしたねとかね
じゃあかつての知識は不完全で苦しいやと
あなた方の今の知識は何ですかね
これも不完全でしょ なんで威張るんですかね
現在知識に しかし 今の知識も不完全です
あと10年経ったったところで
その人々は我々を馬鹿にするでしょうね
あのおじいさんおばあさんたちが本当にアホでしたね
あんなくだらない知識で
間違った知識でとかね
私たちは私たちのおじいさん
おばあさんたちの言っていることが
我々にも孫から言われます
その孫たちにはひ孫たちに言われます
だから いつだって我々はくだらない
不完全な知識で生きているんです
人は常に未熟な知識に頼っているんです
知識にかかる病 肉体だけではなく
知識も病気にかかります
貪瞋痴 傲慢 嫉妬 恨み 落ち込み
興奮 怠けなどの感情に感染すると
劣悪化した知識も病いに陥ります
だから これは仏教だけ発展しているものでしょうがないんだけど
肉体は病気になりますね
精神も病気になります
知識も病気になります
知ってるつもりとは知識の病です
我々は貪瞋痴のせいで
傲慢で 嫉妬 恨み 落ち込みなどの感情で
特に怠けで知っているつもりになるんです
それで知識は病気になっているんです
まあもともと不完全でいい加減なものなんですけど
熱そうなんですけど これ病気になっちゃうと
その上 傲慢 怠け 不安 無知などの感情に感染された時
この病にかかります 知識はね
劣悪化した知識は傲慢と組み合うと病気です
感情と組み合うと病気です
知識と不安が繋げたら
知識は病気になります
知識と恐怖感が組み合わったら
知識が病気です だから仏教みたいに知識も品物扱いしてください
精神も 肉体だけじゃないんで
病気になるのは  1500の感情に感染する知識は健康的ではありません
だから人間には健康的な知識は存在しないんです
人間は知識ばっかし 知識欲ばっかしで生きているんだけど
残念でした すべて病気にかかっています
人間の知識は なぜならば
細菌は1500あります
知識にかかる病気 仏教では煩悩と呼ぶんです
次のテーマは早く知りたい
皆このように思っている
早く知りたいと 自分自身で確かめたいという気持ちはありません
あんたが言ってること
本当？ちょっと待って
私は確かめますと その気持ちないんです
早く知りたいんです 俗世間の知識では
知る尽くすことも すべてを知ることも不可能でありえないんです
だから 誰かさんが私に何か噂を言う
この噂が正しいかないか確かめると言ったってもできないんですよ
それから世の中にたくさん知識があるでしょ
それ全て知ることできる？できません
できても新たな知識が生まれる
例えば 英語を勉強しましょう
英語を勉強して終わっちゃったって言ったら
そうじゃないんです 英語っていうのは世界でたくさん使われている言葉だから
毎日変わるんです 毎日表現が変わる
毎日のように単語の意味が変わっているんですね
だから面倒くさいんですよ
勉強終了しません 知識は主観的なねつ造ですから仕方がありません
知識っていうのは 我々の主観的なところ
仕方がありませんのことで
しかし 知ることがなければ
判断も行動もできません
それで だから早く知りたいんです
こんな確かめる暇がないんです
誰かがね あの黒ごま食べたらがんが治りますよと言ったら
あ そうですかと え？いいえ
あの何々さんがね がんになっちゃってね
それで化学治療をやめちゃって
化学治療をね 黒ごま食べていたんだけど
それで 3ヶ月とかね がんが治ったと
その人言ってることは本当か嘘か
本当にがんが治ったのか
これ黒ごまのせいかと
そんな研究はできんでしょ
だから ああそう では私も今日から黒ごま黒ごまを食っちゃうぞと食いまくっちゃって早く死ぬんです
だからこの早く知りたいということをね
よくある現象でしょう
例えば 日本で本を売りたければ
テーマに 30 分でわかると付ければ
これで全てがわかる 和食と和食のすべての技を身につける本と書けば売れますよ
和食のところが大根の皮を剥くこともできないかもしれませんだけど
私は大学に行っている時はかなり流行ってたんです
で  30 分で大乗仏教のすべてがわかる本
あの教授たちが 50 年間かかって研究してバカやってるんですね
だって 30 分で本読めばわかるんだから
すべて だからそれが人間っていかにバカかっていうことなんです
パソコンが日本で流行っていた
流行り始めた時は 猿にもわかるパソコン入門という本があったんです NEC
会社が出した本です 私は読んでなかったんです NEC
パソコンを使っていたんだけど
あの本は触らなかったんです
だって恥ずかしいんだから
猿にもわかるんだから
日本人が買って読んでいたんです
だからこの早く知りたいという気持ちで
私は早く知りたい気持ちではなくて
円弧輪まで当時で難しかったんだからね
いろいろどうやって使えるのか
どうやって使えるのかと苦労して苦労していくらか使えるようになったんです
今はまあ誰にだってできますけどね
で でも我々にとっては早く知りたいということはなおなってないんです
早く知りたいことの罠
人の話 伝説 伝統 歴史 言い伝え
聖書 霊言 文化 権力 感情
好み 神話 占い マスコミ
流行 習慣などなどになどの何にでも頼るんです
たいていあ 知ってます
知ってますと 面白いことは
日本で霊言を信じる連中が結構いるんですね
相当人間失格だと思いますよ
あの宣教にも出るんだからね
石器時代に送っちゃえばなんか誰かいないんですかね
タイムマシン作れる人が
日本人の半分ぐらいタイムマシンに乗せちゃってね
もう 10万年ぐらい古い古い時代に送っちゃえば
その時代なら神の言葉信じればいいんだからね
そんな時代で なんであんなものに信じるんですかね？あんなもの
誰かが有名人が死んじゃったら
誰か精神的に行かれた人が霊何々さんとの今
霊言 幽言何か何言ってたか
あれは で 本まで出すんです
そこで人の話に乗る 伝統に乗る
これ伝統ですと 歴史に歴史にありましたからと
あるいは言い伝え みんなそう言ってるんだからと
あるいは聖書に書いているんだから信じるでしょうね
霊言文化 これ文化ですからと
はい 正しい 権力者がこれこれやと言ったら
はい 正しいと 例えばアメリカのあの人が何か言ったら
ああ まあそれはそれは通りですと
そこを信じる 感情 好み
それから神話 結構信じていますよ
これが早く知りたいからなんです
それで簡単に知ってるつもり症にかかります
かわいそうで いとも簡単に知識が病気になるんです
占ってもらった時点で知識が病気になります
星を計算した時点でもう病気です
風習と風習でしたっけ？法医学いろいろあるでしょ
信じちゃえば 頼ったらもう知識が病気にかかります
知って判断して行為をする
それは生きることです
曖昧で中途半端な知識で知ってるつもりで生きてみて
皆見事に失敗の人生を過ごしているんです
誰も見事です 見事に失敗しています
なぜならば 知らなきゃ生きられないでしょ？知らなきゃ行動できない
判断できんでしょ でも知るのは面倒くさいでしょ
だから早く知りたいんです
それで神話やら聖書に頼って知ってるつもりになるんです
それで恐ろしい病気にかかった偽造知識で生きていて
見事に失敗する 人生は
はい あの知識の次の側面に入りたいんですけど
今何時でしたっけね  3時に
ちょっと皆さんそこは内容難しいんだからね
ちょっと10分ぐらい休憩いたします
溺れ溺れたくないなら
偽に頼れと で これからの知識の短所を言いましたからね
知識のちょっといいところも言います
溺れないために泳ぐ 泳ぐためには水が必要です
しかし 水だからこそ溺れるんです
なんとなくパラドックスがあるでしょ
人が溺れ 溺れ 溺れ 死にを死ぬ
死に死にかけている場合は
その人助からなくちゃいかんですね
泳ぐでしょ その人を助けてくれるのが誰？水なんです
その人を殺させているのは誰？水なんです
ということで なんとなくパラドキシカルですね
人の熱そうした知識は激流の水のようなものです
それで 我々の知識自体が我々をとんでもないダメージ与えてくれる与える危険なものなんです
知識は熱する知識は これ激流なんです
それは水と同じ だから水に例えたのは知識なんです
知識は激流の水と同じです
そこで我々は水泳を学んだ人は溺れないように
知識の使用方法 知識を得る方法
知識に頼って真理を発見する方法などは学ぶべきです
ポイントは簡単ですね
水は怖いんですよ でも泳ぐことを学びましょう
泳ぐためには水が必要なんです
あの怖いものは必要なんです
そういうわけで 知識がとっても生命に不幸を与える品物なんです
だからといって逃げられないんですね
それで知識の泳ぎ方学ぶんです
知識の泳ぎ方っていうのは
知識を使用方法 知識得る方法
それから知識に頼って真理
本当のことを発見する方法を学ぶなくちゃいけないんです
すべてを知る必要はありません
知識の世界でね たくさん知識ありまして
知識はいつでも不完全で
いつでも変わるもので切りがないんですよ
だからすべて知る必要はないんです
全知は夢の中で見る別な夢です
なんか人間ってのはとんでもないアホで
全知という考えがあるんですよ
神様が全知全能であるとかね
日本人の中でもいるんですね
全知全能のバカが 相当病気なんです
知識とは何だとわかってないんです
人間の歴史と経験が長いなので
生活するために必要な知識は簡単に手に入ります
人間が長い間生きてきたんですよ
我々は長い間 米を稲を作ってきたんですよ
だからそんなのは 1 から学ぶ必要はないんです
もう教えてもらっちゃえば簡単です
例えば科学にしたっても
200年かけて積み重ねた知識ですけど
一旦学校に入ったら 2 3
年で終了です 昔の人々のものはもうすぐ学ぶんです
至って簡単で そんなのは
その知識は不完全で結構です
だから学校で学ぶ科学は不完全で別にいいんじゃない？それで医学も不完全でしょ
まあしょうがないでしょ
それで不完全でありながら
なんとか我々は生きているんだからね
だからまあいいんです
不完全に 生きるとは何？という課題を調べることで人格向上します
だから私が言ったのは
知識はいい加減でいいんです
適当に何か学んで 英語がわからなかったら辞書でも引いてみれば
簡単でしょ そうやっていろいろカニングしたり
いろんな手を回ったり
まあなんとか生きれればいいんです
すべて知ることは不可能でありえないんです
しかし 皆学ぶべきことは
生きるとは何でしょうかと
命とは何なのかと もっと哲学っぽく言えば
私とは何ぞやと 私がいるからでしょう
問題は 私に問題がある
なぜならば私がいるからでしょ
では私とは何ぞやと それがすべての悩み苦しみのスタートポイントです
それを学びましょう それで人格向上します
それだけは自ら確かめなくてはならないのです
私は誰っていうことは自分で確かめてください
例えば地球が丸いっていうことは
人に聞けば ネットでNASAから撮っている写真でも撮ってみれば
あれは嘘かどうかどうでもいいんだよ
あんなのは 宇宙船から撮った地球が回っている画像あるでしょ
ビデオとかね それ見て
ああ やっぱり地球が青いんだとかね
やっぱり地球が丸いんだとかね
自転してるんだとかね
それでいいんです 皆様方
宇宙飛行士になって宇宙に行く必要じゃないんです
自分で確かめなくてもいいんです
で この病気にはこのお薬がいいでしょうと先生に言われたら
飲んでください もう確かめ
ネズミに飲ませたり 犬に飲ませてみたりする必要はないんです
病気が治らなかったら
まあ病気が悪化するか死ぬかどちらかでしょうね
まあ一応まあそんな程度で曖昧でいいんです
しかし 私は何よ これだけは自分で確かめてください
というのが仏教の世界です
はい その道 これから説明します
これ 大事なテーマなんです
結論は保留 いわゆる我々は決して結論に立たない生き方をしなくちゃなんです
何も決めつけない生き方をしてほしいんです
なんか変ですね しかし
この日本に流行っている曖昧中途半端ではないんです
もうちょっとかなり高度なものなんです
データが入り次第 人は結論を導き出そうとする
例えばタレントさんのホテルから出ているのは写真撮られたあと
それは後ろ姿なんですね
だから形に影似ているだけで
それでくだらない雑誌を読んでいる人々は
やっぱりあの人はあの人と不倫しているんだとか噂になるんです
タレントさんもその噂に乗るんです
だってそれで売れるんだから
本当にくだらない世界なんです
そこで人間というのは
そうやってちょっとしたことで結論
何かに警察に何かに何かしらに逮捕したら
もう犯罪だ 有罪だ 終わり
その人の人生は たとえ裁判で無罪になったっても
それから日本社会はその人を追い出すんです
あんた なんとかなんとか捕まえたでしょうに
いえ 私は無罪で解放されましたよと
うーん そうか でも という感じでしょ
あんな性格は来てないんですよ
すぐ結論に達して これ変えないっていうことは
それが決定で最終判断だと最大の間違いを犯します
だから 私の耳に目に何か入ったら
私はすぐ決めちゃって
結論に達して はい 決めた
これは最終判決だと これが最大の罪なんです
すごい間違いなんです
これはディッキパラマースとお釈迦様は言うんです
見解固守という意味なんですね
何か見解を作って これギューッと固守するんです
例えば姑さんが あー意地悪は決まってるんだと
姑さんが悪いんであって
いいところはまるっきり見えない
姑さんにもお嫁さんのもう悪いばっかり
悪いの塊なんですね なんだこりゃと
そんな人間存在するわけないでしょうに
だからそういうこのディッキパラマスのせいで
せっかくの短い人生は地獄になるんです
地獄になるんです 物事を確かめるまで結論を保留するんです
だから なんとなくそんな感じもしますけど
よくわかりませんと あのわかりませんというのはすごくいいんですよ
ちょっと姑さんがね お嫁さんがね
なんかちょっと現代的で
なんか遊び好きなような感じもしますけど
でもよくわからない よくわからないね
人のことはと お嫁さんもね
なんか姑さんがね ちょっと頑固で
ちょっと胸を張っているようにも見えますけど
でもよくわからない そんなのはと
ちょっと私をバカにしたり
怒ったりするんだけど
でもよくわからない あの
よくわからないっていうことがすごくありがたいんです
学校で子供たちがね 勉強しないでごちゃごちゃごちゃ
やっぱりこいつら勉強しないでふざけてるんだけど
でもよくわからない これからどうなるのかと
という状態がとっても立派な状態なんです
ようわかりませんと あの人
コンビニ強盗したでしょうねと
それは事実でしょうと
でもだからといって悪人か
本当に泥棒かという それはよくわかりませんと
良い人間になれませんとかね
これはわかりませんよということで
データはあっても一時的な結論
保留結論にして決定はしない
最終結論は出せない 保留
今までのデータはここまでやと
昨日 自分の国でね 選挙があって
で 大統領選挙で 各地方で数えているでしょ
で 数えていると ちょこっとちょこっと 1箇所地方
あちらこちらから結果が出ると
もうそこで誰が勝っているのかっていうことは読めますよ
ある地方で A さんがこれぐらい
B さんがこれぐらいとか
これ 2番目の地方で A さん
何かこの A さんが勝てそうだなとか
でもわからないでしょ
わからない なんか今までの結果では
この人勝てそうな気がしますけど
よくわかりません まだまだ数えて終わってないんだからと
そこで国民が大体結構発表したところで
もう決まっちゃって 勝ったそう勝ったそうと大騒ぎしてるんだけど
選挙管理局の管理局長が黙ってるんです
黙ってて 最後の 1票を数えて OK と言ったところで発表されるんです
最後の 1票まで もうかなり差があるんですよ
負けた人と勝った人の間で
どれでも最後の1票まで数えなさいと
それは科学的なやり方で
そこですべての国民のなんだかね
数えたら 何々さんがこれぐらい
何々さんがこれぐらい
何々これぐらいとちゃんと数字に出て
これが最終結論 それでもわかりませんよ
選挙でちょっと数え間違ったとかね
ちょっと不正があったとか
裁判かけたら またそのセクションのやり直しになるんだから
数えをまたやり直すことになる
だからやっぱり保留の方がありがたいんです
まあそんなものを言うではなくてもいいんだけど
新しい大統領を選制してなりましたからね
これはもう変えられませんし
まあそんな程度のくだらんことはどうでもいいんです
でも人生のこと 姑さんが悪人やとかね
これだけやめてください
お嫁さんがとんでもない女やと
それだけね やめてください
旦那さんがバカやとかね
奥さんがこんなこんなもんやとかね
そこは保留でよろしいんです
データあるんだけど まあ保留にする
新たなデータが入ったら
前の結論を変える 保留したんだから
最終結論ではないんだだから
新たな新たなデータが入ってくると意見を変えた方がいいです
例えば 姑さんが結婚してもう五
六年間すっごいいじめをいじめられたりしましょう
お嫁さんを でもお嫁さんがみんなそれでもよくわからない
よくわからないと頑張ったところで
どんどん姑さんの気に入っちゃって
すごく仲良くなる可能性もあるでしょうに
ですから データ入る次第
結論を変える これ以上観察するべきものは何もありませんと発見するまで
そのやり方で進むのです
例えば 姑さんが死んじゃったところで
もうデータが入らないでしょ
それでずっと毎日やったことは平等に優しいことはこれこれで
優しくないことはこれこれで
どうでもわからないことはこれこれでとか
まとめて判決を出してもいいんだけど
こんなのどうでもいいでしょ
死んじゃったんだから
人間っていうのは人が死んじゃったら
今までやった悪いことを全部チャラにして
いいことだけ残ってあげたりするんですね
これってまた意味がないんです
まあ行儀作法的に まあ人間としていいことなんですけど
死んだ人の悪口言わないのはね
我々の道徳ですからね
あれは道徳として立派なんですが
でも 死んだ人の悪行為を全部私がチャラにしたからといって
その人の死後どうなるかわからないでしょうに
とにかく我々はそういう生き方をしましょう
決めつけてはつけはしません
データは知る データで一時的な判断もする
しかし いや わからないと
これからはと そのようわからないということは
すごく助け船なんです
これで邪見ってなんですかね
知恵のない人の見解は一般論的に邪見だと言えます
ですから 私は たちの意見っていうのはすべて邪見なんですよ
だってねつ造したものでしょ？それが正しいと思ってるでしょ
例えば酒飲む人が酒飲んだら人付き合いはできますと
相談できますよと思ってるでしょ
本人が正しいと思ってるんです
でも邪見でしょ 会社で相談できるのはみんな酔っ払いだけですかね
会社で酔っ払いは出てきて
あの会社と相談してくださいと頼む
だから嘘のいいところでしょうに
だから我々の意見っていうのは邪見なんですよ
これ一般論で しかし 仏教は一般人の邪見はそんなにゴチャゴチャ言いません
イドメはサッチャンモーガマンニャン
これパーリ語で覚えた方がいいかも
イドメをサッチャンモーガマンニャン
これこそが真理であり
他の見解はすべて間違い
直訳すると イドメは私が言っていることだけ真理であり
他の考えはすべて空むなしいものである
ワイドという意味です
何の根拠もないんだと
これが邪見なんです 私が言っていることは正しい
あんたがと言っていることは全部間違っている
はい さようならと ようわかるという立場が必要なんです
このような立場の人は真理を発見する可能性は失うんです
とても危険なんです 私のねつ造した知識こそが正しいと
私はお釈迦様の生まれ変わりだと言っているバカがいて
その人の信者さんたちがね
かなり結構銀行員やら来て
ずっと私をいじめた時期があったんです
あんたびっくりしないのかと
ブッダが生まれ変わってるんだよと
私はびっくりしましたよ
こんなことを言う人間がいるのかというような感じで
話はまるっきり噛み合わなくてね
毎日毎日毎日 時々この仕事終わって ４
人ぐらい知識人みたいな連中がね
私の部屋に来るんですよ １０
時から 私 夜寝ない人間だから
もうこいつら喋るは喋るは
私も相手して喋るは喋るは
もうぐちゃぐちゃで で
どうなってるのかというと
あの精神的に病気な人が
あれ なんとかの精神病気ですからね
あれは で その病気にかかってる
それこそ真理だと 何々さんが私はブッダの生まれ変わりですと言ってるんだから
その人はブッダの生まれ変わりで
はい 話終了やと  END of the story
なんだこれはと これはイドメはサッチャンモガマンニャンなんです
だからそういう人々には全く真理を発見する可能性がなくなるんです
それが邪見なんです だから考え方邪見ですが
そんなに気にしなくてもいいんです
これこそが真理であり
他みんな嘘であるというところがおかしいんです
ある人が私は神様はゾウの形取ってますよと言っても構いません
もう一人 いやいや ゾウの形じゃなくて
神様はクジラの形ですよと
いいんじゃないか そんなことで
どちらも見てないんだからね
しかし 神様の形は姿がゾウの姿です
決まり終わり 他の考えはすべて間違いですと言っちゃうと邪見です
だから前の考えはただ間違っただけ
証拠なし ねつ造した主観だけで
で 私は神様が象さんとか同じやと思いますけど
でもよくわかりませんと思った方がいいでしょ
隣の友達がいえ 私はいくらなんでもゾウよりはクジラが大きいんだから
クジラの形じゃない？でもよくわかりませんと思った方がいいです
邪見なんですけど あんまり危険性はないんです
あの よくわからないというところとなければ
なぜならばもう一人の人
いえ 神様がすべて作ったんだから
神様の姿は象でもあり
犬でもあり クジラでもあり
ミミズでもあり 微生物でもあり
いろんな形の存在だと
言ったら うーん まああり得るな
でもよくわからない という方がいいんです
ですから お釈迦様が断言禁止しているのは
イダネーバサッチャンモーガマニャンという言葉なんです
私が言っていることが真理であり
他すべて空っぽ 虚しいな
考え虚しいというか 空っぽな考えということなんです
人は真理を知らないかも
しかし 真理を発見する可能性を大事にするべきです
私は皆様も真理は知らないかも
だからといって可能性
真理をする可能性を守ってください
あの文章に言っちゃうと
それがなくなるんです
そういうわけで 我々は真理を知っても知らなくても
真理を守るということになるんです
これはパーリ語でサッチャーヌラッカーナというんです
真理を守る で 言葉はという言葉はお釈迦様が推薦しています
真理を誰も守る必要はありませんよ
地球が丸い それは真理でしょ
誰か守る必要ある？ないんです
では この言葉 自分で真理を発見できる可能性を守るという意味なんです
お釈迦様は短い言葉でサッチャーヌラッカーナ
うーん だからこれはディフェンディング・ザ・トゥルースではなくてね
だからこの真理を このアヌラッカっていうのはプロテクションなんですね
いわゆる壊さない 私が言っていることは正しい
あんたが言っていることは間違っていると言っちゃうと
真理を壊しているんです
だから神様はクジラですよ
象さんの形ですよと言ったっても
間違いですけど しょうがない
なぜならばよくわかりませんとつけますか？いえ
象さんに決まっている
言っちゃうと× ダメ そういうことで
クジラの形だと思うんだけど
でもよくわからないというふうに言っておいた方が
その人に神様の真の姿を発見する可能性あるでしょう
あるいは神様が存在しないならば
それを発見する可能性あるでしょう
だから よくわからないという言葉が必要なんです
イドメワサッチャンモーガマンニャン
この見解こそが真理であり
他の見解は間違いであるというスタンスは禁止って禁じてあるんです
それは禁止 仏教では 仏教はあんま変なものを禁止しているんですね
他の宗教では豚肉食うなよとかね
牛を食うなよと 我々 なんで神が豚を作ったのかと聞きたくなるんだけど
で そんなもの仏教でないんです
酒を飲むなよ場合でもね
脳が壊れますからということで
事実知ってるだけ 判断能力乏しくなる
変な恥ずかしいことをする
瞑想などは絶対できなくなる
だからやめた方がいいんじゃない？という感じで
すごくいいことを言っているんだけど
この場合はもう本当にイドメワサッチャンモーガマンニャンということは禁止なんです
今日 ちょっと長い経典の一部を紹介します
マッジムニカーの95番目の経典
チャンキスッタンというんですね
カーパティカという名前の16歳の若者です
バラモン人の学問を完成した天才がいたんです
あの だいたい40歳になると
頭のすごいいい人が学問完了するんです
バラモン人の昔の 今はそこまでないんだけどね
ヴェーダ聖典というのは膨大だから暗記するんです
だから40歳 45 50
歳になると やっと勉強終わったという程度で
この子は16歳で終わってるんです
とんでもないやつなんですね
そこでもっとこの人の師匠
このチャンキーという偉大なるバラモンなんですけど
かなり大物で お釈迦様に会いたかったんです
それで他のバラモンたちがなんてことをするのかと
あなたほど偉大なる人が
あのゴートマに会っていいわけないでしょうと
ゴートマが若くて その人があなたみたいな長老に挨拶に伺うべきではないかと言っても
チャンキー先生がいえ
違いましょうと どう見ても私が優れているというものは全部あの人は持ってますよと
私はこれに優れて これ優れて
これ優れ これと言ってリストはね
全部あの人は持ってますよと
しかしもう一つ このゴートマさんが今私たちの地方に来ているんだと
旅途中で ということは
私たちにとってお客様ですと
日本でも客は神様やという言葉がありますね
あれは漢字が漢字が違いますけど
インド文化では客は神様なんです
金くれるんだからっていう意味じゃないんです
だから客の面倒を見ることは
本当に神様のお世話をすることなんです
だからバラモン人も神様のお世話するでしょ
だからこのチャンキーさんが釈尊が客ですと
あんたどうする？客に礼をして挨拶をして伺うのは仕事だと
だから私が行きますよと
行った 行った時はこのカーパティキという青年も行ったんです
行って 長老の80歳ぐらいの長老のバラモンたちとお釈迦様が喋っているんです
喋る長老たちよりこいつは天才でしょ
イライラしているんです
イライラして 話の間に口を挟んだんです
ただ お釈迦様はものすごく怒鳴ったんです
あのね お前は 我々長老たちが喋っている間に話を挟むってどういうことかと
黙っていなさいと 言ったらどうしようもなく控えたんです
お釈迦様は全部計画してやっています
そうすると このチャンキー師匠がお釈迦様
この子をけなさない方がいいんだと
こいつはものすごい人だと
で 褒めて紹介してあげたんですね
私たちとぶっきり同じ知識で能力で
こんな若者だと お釈迦様はうんとなんとも言わないんですね
そうすると このカーパティカ若者もお釈迦様が私の顔を見たとき質問しますと
言って お釈迦様は長老たちの話が終わって
会話が終わって この若者の顔を見たんです
見たら あ 私と対話したいんだとわかって
それで質問を始めたんです
で 最初の質問はすごく面白いんだけど
カットしました いわゆるこの知ってるつもりはいかにバカバカらしいかという対話なんですね
彼がこう言ったんです
我々の伝統では このヴェーダ聖典だけ正しくて
他の教えは間違っているんだと私の師匠たちが教えているんだよと言ったら
お釈迦様 あ そう ということは
あなた方の師匠たちが私はそれ確かめました
真理であることを 私でこれを発見しましたと言っている
いえ そう言ってない ああ
そう では 師匠たちの師匠たち
そう言ったの？ヴェーダ聖典の教えが真理であると我々は確かめましたと言ってますかと聞いたら
いえ そんなこと言ってないんだと
では 師匠たちの師匠たち
そのふうに言ったの いえ
言ってないんだと では
その師匠たちの師匠たちの師匠たち
これでさかのぼっていくんですね
言って  7代目まで行ってね
7代目の師匠たちと言ったのかと
言ってないんだと では聞きますけど
ヴェーダ聖典作ったアッタカ
ヴァーマカ ヴァーマデウェッサ
ウェッサ ウェス ウェッサブー
ヤマッタグ アンギーラス
バーラドゥージ なんだらかんだらという８人ぐらいいますね
そういうヴェーダ聖典を書いた聖人たちが
我はこれを真実である
真理であると発見しましたと経験しましたと言っているんですかと
いえ そんなこと言ってないんだと
要はお釈迦様があのバラモン人と同じくすべて丸暗記で知っているんです
だからしょうがないんです
嘘を言ったって嘘を言えないんです
お釈迦様の前に ということはね
前の人の目も見えない
その人の末は次に目が見えない人が捕まっている
その人の末は次の目が見えない人が捕まっている
次の人を目が見えないんだから
前の人の末を捕まっている
だから頭からよっぽどまで全部目が見えない人々は
前の人の末に捕まっているだけでしょねと
どういうことかと だからこれこそ真理だと言うなよと
あんたは真理を冒涜しているんだと
真理を守りなさいよと
初めてあの言葉が出てきたんです
真理を守りなさいと うん
これこそが真理でありというスタンスの間違いを示してから
サッチャーのラッカーナについて説明してあげるんです
真理を守りなさい  1人はこれが真理であると信じている
いわゆる信仰ですね かもしれません
アマテラス大神が日本の国を作りましたと
そう信じているかもしれませんよ
別に その時私はこのように信じていますと言えば真理を守られます
それだけ キリスト教の世界ではね
いろんな宗派があるでしょ
だから 例えばモルモン教もキリスト教かどうかよくわかりませんだけど
私はモルモン教の教えで説かれている神が正しいと信じていますと言えばいいんです
モルモン教で説かれている神だけ正しい
他嘘よと言っちゃるとアウト
もうアウトです 私はどちらかというとプロテスタントの方が信じていますと言えば OK なんです
プロテスタントの教えが正しくて
カトリックが間違っていると言っちゃうと
これはアウトなんです
だから信仰があって 何か信じているならば
私は信じていますと言いなさいよと
2番目 好み 私はこの意見は好み
伝承はこんなもんで あるいは言い伝え
言い伝えで信じるものもあるでしょ
それから可能性 どう考えてもこれが真理である可能性あるなとかね
言ったら可能性であると
私はまるまるが真理だという可能性があると思いますと
あの言葉をつけてほしいんです
条件 それから 5番目 自分で納得している
まあ私はアッラーよりはイエホワの方が納得しているんだと
納得しているんだと言ってください
アッラーよりイエホワ正しいではなくて
このように人間が自分で確かめないで
信仰 好み 伝承 言い伝え
可能性 あるいは納得という立場で真理だと思ってますから
その人々は真理を守っていない
だから この自分のこのスタンスを言ってくださいとお釈迦様は言うんです
その時も私の好み云々と言えば
真理守っているのです
決してこれは真理とは言えない
これこそ正しい 他間違っているとはよそれは言わない
これは私の信仰です 我々の伝統はこんなもんです
私の納得はこんなもんですと言えば OK
安全です これで真理を守ることになります
次 真理を発見する 真理を守ることと発見することは違います
それはサッチャーの暴動と呼ぶんです
この道は長いんです 真理を発見する
本当は他ないかと まず語る人の心を調べる
例えば神父さんでもいいし
ローマ教皇でもいいし
お釈迦様でもいいし 喋ってるでしょ
この人は性格はなんなのかを調べるんです
貪瞋痴に汚染している人か否かを調べるんです
話の内容から 実践している人々の性格から判断すると
語り手の心は汚染されていないと理解できる
仏教の場合でも 仏教を実践している人々の性格も調べてみる
たらまあなかなかいい人間やと
喋っている人の性格は問題はありませんと
インチキ詐欺はないんだと
貪瞋痴はありませんと
という風に すぐ聞くんじゃなくて
先生の話 ブッダの話 ちょっと調べなさいよと
次に あ 信頼できる 心は汚れていない
弟子たちを見たら なかなか立派な人格者で
ああ この人を信頼できると信頼するんです
信頼する人を尋ねる そこで仏教で信仰はこれなんですね
調べて信頼できる サッダ
信頼できるならば尋ねてください
その人と付き合う 尋ねてウパサンカントパーリパーシティ
いきなり話を聞かなくてもいいんです
まず そのキリスト様と付き合ってみる
付き合ってみると どんどん耳を傾ける
パイルパーさんと総たんをだはて
それから真理 話を聞く
大仁総統ダンマンスナーティ
それから教えを覚える
あの聞いただけではダメなんですよ
このデータ脳に記憶 記憶しておかないと
なぜならばデータを比較したり
いろんなことをやったりするような脳なんですね
だから聞いて覚える必要があるんです
教えの意味を調べる だから覚えてほしい
脳で覚えてから これはこれで
これはこれで これはこれで
こういうことでとかね
自分で頭で考えてみるんです
意味を考えてみるんです
どんな意味でしょうかと
意味を調べると納得する
正しい真理だったら 教えたのはね
もう意味は合っている
もう納得 納得と納得 アッタウパーリカンとダンマニッジャーナンカマンティ
納得したら意欲が生じる
あ これは真理 納得 そうすると意欲が
あ やってみようという意欲が生じる
ダンマニッジャーナカンティアセitanをだえて意欲が生じると精進する
ではやってみようと 頑張ろう
チャンダジャートウッサーハティ
精進しては比較する 仏教の場合は
実践してどうなったのか
また実践してどうなったのかと
精進しては比較する ウッサーヒットアトリエティ
ここまでの修行の結果どうですかね
これ前の自分の状態はどうですかねとか
ちょっと調べてみる トライットアパダハティ
比較してさらに精進する
あ ここまではこうこうなりました
じゃあもっと頑張ってみる
はい ここまでなりました
もっと頑張ってみる そういう風にどんどん真理に達するまで頑張ってみるんです
精進努力を続けると 自分で最高の真理を体験する
精進する 比較する 精進する
比較する 精進する 比較する
これでどんどんどんどん心が成長して
最高の真理に達するんです
智慧で貫くことができる
智慧が現れて すべての物事は根こそ貫いて真理を発見します
パヒタット様のカーエナチーヴァ
パラマサッチャンサッチカロティ
パンニャーイチナン アティヴィッジャパッセティ
真理体験するんです これが真理を発見することですが
真理に達したことではありません
またありますよ ステージが
もう真理を発見しました
体で経験しました まだ真理に
自分が納得ないんです
エッタータコバハラドワディサッチャヌボードホティナトゥエタワサッチャヌパッティホティ
次に真理に達する 発見した体験した真理を使用することで
実践することで 復習することで真理に達するんです
例えばヴィパッサナー瞑想はですから
ヴィパッサナー瞑想を実践すると
どんどん無常はわかる
因果法則がわかってくる
あ やっぱりこれしかないやと納得する
それから無常に無常を先頭にして生きてみる
因果法則を観察しながら生きてみる
そうやってある程度で生き方
この瞑想経験に基づいて生きてみなくちゃあかんです
そうすると煩悩がなくなって解脱に達するんです
ここで煩悩を断ってって一つ大きい多いんですけど
解脱に達することを意味します
はい それで解脱に達します
あなたヴィパッサナー瞑想しただけですれません
ヴィパッサナー瞑想すると智慧が現れてくるんです
真理を発見するんです
それから真理に沿って生活してみるんです
インチキ 根性ではなくて
そう生活していると 心からすべての煩悩が落ちるんです
知ってるつもりでは 成長の道の一歩さえも進まないんです
だからすべて終わり 知ってるつもりでいると
みんな知ってるつもりでいたいんです
面倒くさいながら はい
いかに危険かと知ってるつもりは
だから我々を助けてくれる言葉はいたって簡単
よくわからない 一応これ信じていますけど
よくわからない その結論
それについてよくわからないということで頑張ってみてください
そうすると 知ってるつもりはなくなるんです
やってるつもりは今日は話しません
大したことないんです
知ってるつもり症の問題ですね
知ってるつもりの人はやってるつもりでしょ
本当はやってないのに
自分の主観で自分の殻の中にいてやっているつもりになってます
なります 客観的に結果があるのか否かを調べてないんですね
ちょっと間違いありますけど
まあ補ってください 調べてないんです
調べないんです だから
やってるつもりの人々はやってるつもりなんですけど
結果見てくださいよと
結果がなかったらやってないでしょ
ご飯炊いたつもりですけど
釜にご飯なければやってないでしょ
だからやってるつもりっていうのは結果でわかりますから
まあそんなに講演で喋るぐらいのものではないと思いました
結果がなければ 手ごたえがなければ
ただやってるつもりだけです
これで終了です ありがとうございます
お話ありがとうございました
何度かお話を伺わせていただいているんですけれども
私もヴィパッサナーとか瞑想を進めさせていただいて
自分がとても楽になって生きるのが幸せを感じるようになってきたなと思っているんですけども
そしたら周りの人たちが煩悩にいろいろちょっと幸せっていうか
ちょっといろいろ苦しみながら生きてるなっていうのをちょっと気になるようになってきてしまって
自分はどんどん楽になってるんですけど
そうするとなんかどんどん周りの人が苦しんでるのを見て
何とかできないものかなと思ってしまってですね
でもちょっと仏教ですか
宗教ってあんまり周りに勧めるものでもないですし
こうしたらいいんじゃないってアドバイス程度しかできないというか
それでどういうアプローチをしたらいいのかなっていうのは
ちょっと最近悩みになってきてしまってですね
ちょっとそれでちょっと長老のポイントを伺いたいなと思いまして
ぜひお願いいたします
それでいいと思いますよ
こうしたらどう？という風に
ちょっと具体的なアドバイスだけしてあげればね
説教する必要はないので
できるだけ避けた方がいいんです
世界がもう嘘ばっかりで
仏教しか人間に学ぶべきものは存在すらしないのに
それを言われるとすごく気持ち悪くなるんですね
これ当然のことなんですよ
みんな無知ですからね
知ってるつもりでいるんだからね
知ってるつもりの人に
いや これ違いますと言われると腹が立ちますね
ですから 余計な力のない方々はね
余計なことをしないで
こうしたらどう こうしたらどうとかね
私ならこうやってますよとかね
私ならこうしましょうって
そういうふうな優しいやり取りで十分だと思いますね
それで誰かさんがね お前おかしい
なんでこんなに何でもバチバチと答えるんでしょうか？と言ったら
実は秘密がありますと
だから聞いたら仏教の話を言ってあげてください
はい  今お話を伺った時には
おそらくは知ってるつもりってあるなと思うんですけれど
やはり普通に生活していると
ついついまたこう知ってるつもりがだんだん出てきて
気づいたらまた溜まってるっていうことがよくあるかなと思うんですが
こう日々気づき続けるために何かやった方がいいことというか
ヴィパッサナーというのも一つだと思うんですけれど
それでもやっぱり落ちるということが多いので
どうすれば日々気づき続けられるかっていうのを教えていただけると
これは講演の中で言いました
保留 知ってるつもり これはこうじゃないかなという意見は
まあ本当は今のデータではこういうことにしますけど
保留でよくわかりませんと
よくわかりませんということをすごく大事にしてください
呪文のように お前バカやと言ってもいいんだけど
よくわかりません というふりでください
はい 講演会3回目の本当に
まあ全くこの教えというものをまだ理解できていない
本当に始めたばかりの
勉強始めたばかりの者と申しますけれども
実は個人的な悩みを聞いていただいてよろしいでしょうか
長老の本は結構なかなりの数を読ませていただいております
本だけの世界でいろいろ私は考えていたんですけれども
そうすると読めば読むほど自分がやっていることが最近苦しくなってきて
というのは 私はちょっと秋田県の鳥海山だけど
すごく田舎であまり産業もないところのふるさとを振興しようって
ふるさとをに食べて応援しようという
そういうふるさと会っていう仲間の幹事の一人になっていて
鳥海山麓で育てる牛 百合牛というものを東京に広めていこうという活動に参加させていただいて
どんどん百合牛を食べているんですけども
その牛肉を食べることが苦しくなってきたんですが
ただ 仲間に私の本当の気持ちを言うと
一生懸命ふるさとを応援している仲間をもうなんか傷つけるように気になるし
優しい気持ちでなんか健康に悪いことをやっているの仲間にどうやってこれから付き合っていったらいいのか
とても最近苦しんでいますか
長老のご指導を見たいと思います
うん ちょっと佐藤さん
ちょっとわからないところいくつかありましたけど
秋田県で 秋田県でその土地で取れる牛を牛肉を東京で広めていこうっていうキャンペーンにする人たちの仲間に入っていて
そのそういうことをやっているんですけど
仏教の先生の本を読んだりすると
なんかそういうことをするのがだんだん苦しくなってきた
ですけど そういう自分の本当の気持ちを言うと
その自分の一緒にキャンペーンをやってる人たちを傷つけ
傷つけちゃうことにもなるので
そういう葛藤があって
すごく精神的に苦しくなっているという
あのね これはなんとか中立的に解決できるとは思いますけどね
じゃああの秋田県のものはね
まあやっぱりどんどん東京に広げてほしいと
これには問題ありませんと
で 田舎にもね まあ収入が入ってほしいやと
秋田県でいえば牛肉だけでしょうかねとかね
もっと秋田県丸ごと広げるようにしましょうよと
私はこの動物殺すことはどうっても痛くて
もうたまらないんだと
すごくこの精神的に苦痛を感じるんだと
しかし 秋田県を愛することには問題ありませんと
その通り  え？ うん おっしゃる通りで
今も直前に 2月10日に
2月10日の牛肉を食べる会というものに 2万円出して参加しなきゃいけないんですけども
もう牛肉を食べることすら気持ち悪くなっている自分に
どうやってその仲間と楽しく牛肉を食べることができるのか
そこがもう気持ちがどうもあんな川に牛肉を
こんな脂っぽいものを牛肉食べてやめようよとも
そこは言いたいけど言えない
でも何も食べないとどうしたの？ってみんなが心配すると思うし
目の前の 2月10日の牛肉を食べる会っていうので悩んでます
牛肉を食べる会って まあ別に肉食べても肉食べたからといって殺生になるわけじゃなくて
これはどんどん力をつけて広げよう広げようすることがちょっと残酷なんですね
ごく普通に牛肉も食べる
豚肉も食べるっていうのはね
そんなに大きい問題ではないと思いますけど
だからとことん広げてやるやるぞというね
のは ちょっとちょびっと残酷なんですね
まあ人間は俗世間はそんなもんだからね
我々一人の力ではね どうすることもできないし
だからまあいろいろ方法ありますよ 2
万円払って参加しないこともできるし
これ悔しいんだったらどうしましょうかね 2
万円まで払って参加しないのはね
うーん 払って まあしょうがないっていうことで
どうせ死んじゃったんだと
この牛さんたちがね だからありがたくいただいて
自分の瞑想でもしますと
わかりました ありがとうございます
ちょうどのお話ありがとうございました
我々が人生で出会ういろいろな出来事に対して
即座に劣等するんだと 10
人いれば10人トイレの劣等があるんだということだと思いますけど
我々の体の癖もありますけれど
心の方にはもっと根深い習慣
癖があるんですね それは言わば潜在意識の呼吸が一つのパターンのような形で根深く残っていると
それを修正しないで劣等をやめるというのはかなり困難だなと
我々はいろんな出来事
いろんな人に会った時に
瞬時に劣等がスタートできるんですね
そうしますと 我々のそういう深い心の心を
いわば修正するといいますか
いう方法 技法としては
そのヴィパッサナー あるいはサマタというものを
いわば長く続けていくということでよろしいでしょうか
うん あの捏造っていうのはそう簡単にはやめられませんよ
だから捏造して生きてるんだからね
捏造を取り上げたらもう生きていられなくなるんです
だからこれは我々は 例えば子供とふざけてゲームやったり遊んだりもしますけど
自分が大人であることも忘れないというね
例えば子供にウサギちゃんがその時はこうやったとか
なんか本当のことのようにストーリーを言ってあげてるでしょ
私もそうやりますよ すごく論理的に
その時ウサギちゃんはね
こう言いましたよとかね
で だから子供にはそうやって言うんだけど
大人の世界は大人の世界で
それもちゃんと区別しておく
だから会社ではいろんなところで捏造世界であるとわかった方が
より捏造を維持管理できるんです
捏造が本当だと思っているんだからやられちゃうんです
まあどうせ捏造だからね
こういう風に捏造したらどう？っていう感じでね
これ自分の心の中でこの 2次元をね
置いといてください そうすると結構便利になります
だから この私も実際そういうことで
自分の世界は別で 人間と付き合う場合はね
そこをそのレベルにビシッと合わせちゃうんですよ
この間スリランカ行って帰りましたけどね
まあ 1週間ぐらいだったけどね
もうちっちゃな子供たち
子供ずっと周りで 時間そうしたら出て行かない
家に帰らない 家に帰ったっても
すっとすっとまた戻ってくるんです
しょうがないんですよ
もうで 私のアイパッドやら全部機械をもう奪われちゃって
で 私も本読みたいんだけどね
もうしょうがないんです
で なぜかというと 私はいろいろゲーム買ってるんで
買ってるんだけど 自分できないんで
これ見事にやってるんですね
だからまあ子供たちとまあどこまで進んだの？とかね
そこまで行ったの？とかね
そちらに合わせながら
私はゲーム入ってないという風に Kindle も持っていってね
私は Kindle に本をダウンロードして
それずっと読んでるんですね
だから私は瞑想教えて妄想やとかね
もう何やこれやとかのはないんです
その場合は私のことをどう思ってるかもわからない
あの子供たちが こんなややこしい説法する人間かとさっぱり知らないでしょ
子供にご飯あげている
子供をちゃんと寝かしてあげている
で 面倒見てあげているおじいさんだと思っていると思いますよ
だから飛んでくるんです
来たら そういうことで
誰にだってまあいろいろそれに
なんていう TPO ですね
それに合わせて生きることになるんです
しかし 執着がなければ固執しなければ楽なんです
そういうふうに この寝相は寝相であるということを
この自分の心の中に置いておくもので
そちらにも私にも寝相しないと生きていられないんです
私も野菜を買う場合はキャベツあるでしょうに
一つ選ぶんですよ じゃあこちらにしましょうと
寝相でしょ それは自分の都合で柔らかい
押してみたら なんか中に指が入ると
これ面倒くさい 切る時もうまくいかない
飛び散ったりする だから押してみて
硬い あ これはいい これはい
これ買いましょうという感じで
自分の都合で寝相するんです
しかし それが真理やとは思ったことは一度もないんです
どうせキャベツやと思います
何食ったっても同じこっちゃやということも知ってるんです
そういうふうに何とか調整してみてください
はい  お話どうもありがとうございました
因果 因果関係についてお尋ねしたいんですけれども
ちょうどおっしゃったように
ガラスが落ちたら割れてコップがなくなるのは大変なので
そういった関係で因果関係で説明されたと思うんですけれども
その 1対 1の関係ではなくて
コップが床に落ちて割れて
なおかつ何々がこぼれるとか
そういう因果関係っていうのは普通に違和感っていうものじゃないかなというふうに
いつも因果関係の探求でいいんだと思ってたんですけども
そこら辺はどうなんでしょうか
おっしゃる通りです あの
科学っていうのは その様々なことの中から確定してできるものを探していくんですね
例えばガラスは落ちても割れる
金槌で殴っても割れるとかね
それで科学者 が ガラスにこれぐらい力がこれぐらい面積に入れば割れますよと計算するでしょ
そんなもんなんだ だから様々なたくさん条件が揃って起きる出来事なんですね
例えば これぐらいの力が入ったらガラスが割れるぞと思っても
ガラス全体に 例えば下と上からじっと力が上げても割れないということもありますね
面白い 卵割るでしょ ちょっとプッとやったら割れるでしょ
あの卵のお腹の方刺したら割れますけど
できれば卵のお尻と頭の方がこうやって押してみてください
いくら力入れても割れないんです
だからこのいろいろ条件複雑なわけです
因果関係を明らかにするっていうのは
現象を見ただけでは簡単にはわからない
もう本当に難しいんです
人間にはかなり因果関係を知り尽くすことはもう不可能です
だからお釈迦様がすべてわからなくても結構ですから
心と心の変化するシステムだけ覚えてくださいと
それは明確に説かれてあります
でも すべての世界は因果関係なんです
コップだとコップが落ちて割れたという現象があるというのは
実際にその落ちたのか
それとも下から何か尖ったものがあったのか
そこら辺もわからないので
実際の問題だと因果関係の決定がすごく難しいというふうに思っているんですね
まあだから因果関係ですと
すべてはとね 大ざっぱに決めるんです
例えば 私はどうやって病気になるのかとはっきり言えないでしょう
でも因果関係なんです
結果があるのは何か原因がありますよという意味の因果関係
うん すべて原因があって現れているんです
その この結果の原因はこれですよっていう意味ではないんでしょうか
言えるところは言います
でも すべて言ったわけじゃないんですね
だいたいまあ大体なんて言いますか
メインポイントだけね
言えればいいんですね
例えば人を鉄砲で撃たれたとしましょう
人が死んじゃったんですね
鉄砲で 本当は鉄砲で撃たれて死んだわけじゃないんです
鉄砲の弾で穴開いただけなんです
しかし その人が心臓に穴開けて大量出血で死ぬんですね
だから私はこの間大量出血で死にましたから
お医者さんの話で だからあなたは無罪とは言えないでしょ
一般的にやっぱり撃たれて死にましたと言うんでしょ
そういうふうにまあ世界になっちゃうんです
うん 先ほど 先ほどの話に戻るんですけれど
まあ生きていく上ではですね
周りに合わせるっていうことをしなきゃならないということでいきますと
日本では嘘も方便っていうことあるんですけど
まあやっぱりそういう方便的な言い方も時々仏教書で出てくるんですけど
それはやむを得ないっていうことでよろしいんでしょうか
いや これはちょっとやばいですね
嘘は  嘘はよくないんですね
ただ 方便的に合わせるっていうことは
だから人に合わせますけど
乗らない  知ってればいいですね
多少そういうことをやってるんだって意識が
例えば子供と遊ぶのはいいんだけど
自分も子供になったつもりで乗ってしまっちゃって
バカになる必要はないんですよ
子供が遊んでいるときはいろんな途中でいろんなことをするんですから
大人として子供を守ることもしなくちゃあかんですよ
だから 私の周りに子供はスリランカの場合
群がってくるのはそういうことなんです
私は一緒になっていろんなことをやっていながら
大人として子供を守っているんですね
だから 子供は親と一緒にいるより
私と一緒にいることが安心だと思っているんです
だから我々は合わせるんだけど
乗ることをしません それから
嘘を言っても それは方便ではなくて
自分がバカということなんですね
頭使っちゃうと嘘を言わないで
なんか別な方法で言えるんですね
私なら何か漫才作るんです
漫才だから こと聞いてる人々は
それは漫才で本当のものではないともうとっくにわかってるんです
そこで漫才で相手からかったら
言いたいことはもう理解しているんです
そういう風にも よく冗談を言ったり
何か笑わせて いろんな方法で嘘だけ避けるということで
自分の頭が良くなるんですね
私はそうやって嘘は避けるんです
しかし いろんなストーリー作って言うんです
それで結局自分の頭が回転するんです
何か子供が何か変なことをやったら
どんなストーリーでいいかなとかね
すぐさっさっさっと新しいストーリーを組み立てるんです
組み立ててそれを言うんです
だからそういうふうに嘘の嘘は方便ではありません
嘘は下手な人の下手なやり方なんです
ありがとうございます
だから人が怒ったら殴っちゃえと
それは方便やと 方便じゃないでしょうに
殴ったら痛くなって この人は学ぶそうと
違います だから同じことでね
もう殴ったら殴り返せと
殺したら殺し返せと 奪ったら奪い返せと
のは もうもう馬鹿な世界が言ってることで
仏教の言葉ではありません
怒ったら慈しみで勝負しなさいと
で そういうふうに殴りに来たら
もう忍耐で 勝負しなさいと
全く反対の選び出してくださいと
あんたそんなにも殴りたい？じゃあ殴って
言っちゃうと殴れなくなるんですよ
だから勝ちでしょ こちらは
だから嘘は方便ではございません
これは日本仏教でできた言葉かもしれませんね
それはしょうがない 日本仏教は嘘だからね
善秀はちょっと置いておきますけどね
はい  よろしくお願いします
男の人が怖いことがあるのですが
どうやって生きていったらいいかなと思っています
恐怖の感情でいっぱいになってしまうことがあるので
気にせず明るくいた方がいいのか
それとも多少気をつけて生きていた方がいいのか
自分の中でどうしたらいいかわからなくて
うん  女性の質問というのは
すごくお欲しければ 結構トラブったことがありますからね
特に女性が男性にそういう質問する場合はね
まあ結構問題ありまして
これはもう個人的に聞かなくちゃあかんやと思います
一応一般的な答え出します
これ勘違いです 男が女の方怖いんです
で 女性が男が怖いと思うこと自体がおかしいんです
どんな凶暴な男を迎えても
お前何よと 向かって言ったら向こうは下がります
それは遺伝子的にできないんです
私に対しても向かって男たちが来たら
もうところ構わずもうやっつけます
女の人とか喧嘩になったらという風に後ろに行くんです
ですから 私さえも そういうことで
あなた自信持って生きてみたら
はい 何をと言って言ってしまえば相手は引くんですね
ん？ 何を  そうそうそうそう
だから女ってのは絶対負けたくないでしょ
たとえ間違っても認めません
だからまあそれでいいんじゃない？何という感じで
もう負けないで前に進むんです
でないと女性は務めません
世界は 生命は女性が育てて
産んで 育てて守るものなんです
この方々は弱くて 怯えていると世界の終わりです
世紀末です だから 女性で生まれる誰にでも遺伝子的にその能力があるんです
怖いのは我々の方です
ありがとうございます
はい  インターネットで 1週間ほど前にここの存在を知りまして
初めて来ました で どのように質問していいか
ちょっと言葉を選ぶ次第ですけども
私の方では女房が弱く
悲しいことはないの 私も息子の自営業がうまく行っていってないこととか
ぼやいたりとかしております
さらに 妻より私の方が知識が多いので
妻としては私のいい加減なことについて妻に反発を持つのは持ってるんですけども
こういう状態で 妻が最近
この 3 4ヶ月で記憶障害の 5 分前のことを忘れるような状態になってるわけなんですけども
今日の話の中で知識だとか学ぶとか
そういうことが全然できる環境でもないし
それでも理解はしないだろうし
私の方の対応としてはどういうふうにすればいいでしょうか
アドバイスをお願いいたします
ちょっと耳が  奥様が記憶障害
簡単に言うならばアルツハイマーというか
そういうような感じですね
いわゆる記憶障害というような分類があって
原因とかいうのも医学的にはっきりしないですね
例えばうつだとか 記憶をなくする状況というのは
例えば強烈なパニックがあっても
そういうのになる場合もあるし
はっきり原因はわかんないですけど
そういう状況でございます
ですので ものを何かするというか
積極性もだんだんなくなってくるし
台所で食器の置き場所もわからなくなっているような状態です
こういう説明でよろしいでしょうか
えっと 大丈夫です なんか私は耳が悪くてね
なんかすごい音エコーみたいになっちゃって
あんまり言葉が明確にならないんですね
まあ一応なんとかわかったような感じでで答えますけど
こんなややこしいガチャガチャガチャガチャ考えない方がいいんじゃないんですかね
今の状況を見てそれに合わせればその話ですよ
あんまり知識であれやこれやと考えると
全てメスそうだから一つも当たりません
だからその場で その場で
その場で その場 例えば食器洗うの忘れたならば
それなりにどうすればよろしいかとかね
洗ってちょうだいと頼むとかね
なんとかその場で解決するという風にした方が楽やと思います
で 今更あなたは仏教を学んでくださいという話にならんだからね
脳が壊れていくとね まあもう復活できないし
脳を開発する方法はありますけど
ものすごく道が長いんで
それもね これも専門家
脳科学の専門家と一緒に訓練しなくちゃいけないし
方法を知ってますけど
私にはそんな仕事をしてはいけませんだからね
脳がたとえ壊れていっても
理性を蘇ることはそんなに難しくない
だから私の父親が腎臓がもう全然機能停止しちゃって
医者がね まあこの年になると腎臓は移植しますからね
もう移植しなきゃもう頭が壊れてしまいますよと
私は移植は反対で 死ぬ時はもう誰だって死にますから
自然に死んでほしいっていう感じで
移植は絶対ダメっていうことで
自分の中で それで当然
父親がもうわけもわからないことをしゃべり出しちゃって
しゃべるはしゃべるはしゃべるをしゃべるはしゃべるは
自分の それで最後に姉の家に住んでたんだけど
姉の名前さえもわからないんです
私のこと知ってるんです
姉はすごく悲しいんですね
一番可愛がってた自分の名前を忘れてるんだとかね
で 私は笑ってな そう 忘れてるっていう感じで
でも私はやっぱり人間として知識と理性失ったら非常に困りますよと
たった 5分 6分以内でもう理性だけは生き返ってもらったんです
で それは父親だからできるんだよって
他の人にはこれやってはいけないことでね
だからその余計な期待をしないでね
物事は壊れていきますから
で 壊れる状態に合わせればいいんです
日本でないんだけど 私たちの国では車買ったらもうずっと使うんです
5年  6年  10年と全然へっちゃら
それで車っていうのは壊れるでしょう
いろんなところ で 壊れるものはもうあんまり贅沢なものだったらそれは捨てちゃう
ブレーキが壊れると そこは何か入れ替えたり
そうやって調整しながら使う
まあそういうことを人生にも同じことで
人生は死ぬまでのもんだから
ものを忘れるならば ではどんな程度で忘れるのか
どこでどこで我々は補わなくちゃいけないのかというようなことで
慈しみで すごく優しくて対応していく
優しい 本当にこの人が元気な時はすごくいろんなことを頑張ってくれたんだから
もう恩返ししなくちゃいけないんだと
とにかく悩まないようにしてあげてください
悩まないように 怒らないように
本人がなんとかいくら物事を忘れても
ニコニコといられるようにしてあげてください
で 自分の名前を忘れちゃったら
もう隣のおじさんだよとかね
なんとか冗談言ったりして
で あなた気に入ったんだよという感じで冗談を言えばね
もう本人が楽しくなるでしょうね
そういう風にこの人生を楽しく過ごせるように努力
協力してあげてください
あまり偉そうなこと考えない方がいいんです
はい 以上です  ありがとうございました
それではまだまだあると思うんですけど
時間の関係でこれで終了したいと思います
最後に回向の文ということを唱えて終了としたいと思います
かしこしください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬礼し
戒をまとめ 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして見立てが得られますように
サッビーテョ ワッジャントー サッバロゴー ウィナッサトー マテー バワット パンタラーヨー スティーディ ガイコー
バワ バワトゥ サッバ マングラッカン トゥ サッバ デヴィタ サッバ ブッダ アヌバーヴェーナ サッバ ダン
マ アヌバーヴェーナ サッバ サンガ アヌバーヴェーナ サダ スッティ バワントゥ テ アビワダナ シーリ
ッサ ニッチャン ワッダ パチャイノ チャッターロ ダンマ ワッダンテ ヤーユ ワンノウ スカン バラム アユラーロー
ギャ サンパッティ サッバ サンパッティ メーワチャ アトー リッンバーナ サンパッティ イミナ テー サミッジョトゥ
どうもありがとうございました